[Music]
on this Friday night deadly mistake what
the Israeli military did that led to
three Israeli hostages being killed as
pressure mounts on the IDF to dial down
its offensive innocent people's lives
should be sacred and protected tragedy
strikes a Quebec hockey rank the
accident that took the life of an
11-year-old boy pledging new housing in
Vancouver the deal the feds in one of
Canada's most most expensive cities have
constructed and a campaign with serious
legs you can put a new pair of socks on
the next morning A New Brunswick pairs
heartwarming and
[Music]
feetwarmers good evening we begin
tonight with breaking news on the
hostage situation in Gaza in the past 24
hours six men being held by Hamas have
been killed three of them mistakenly
killed by the Israeli
military Israeli Defense Forces have
taken responsibility for The Accidental
deaths and have expressed sorrow over
the deadly mistake Daniel hjan joins us
now from Jerusalem Danielle what do we
know about how this happened Farah the
IDF said tonight that during combat in
Northern Gaza Israeli soldiers
mistakenly identified three Israeli
hostages and open fire all three were
killed afterwards when they were
searching the area there were concerns
over the identities of the three
deceased men their bodies were then
transferred to Israeli territory for
examination and that's how they were
able to confirm their identities all
three men were in their 20s one of them
an Arab from the bedwin community the
idf's initial assessments that they
either managed to flee from captivity or
were abandoned by their C CHS in the
midst of the fighting a spokesperson was
also unable to answer the question
whether or not the three men had put
their hands up or shouted in Hebrew
that's still unclear the Israeli
military says this was a tragic error
and that an investigation is now
underway but Farah this is exactly what
the families of the hostages have been
fearing all along that their loved ones
would be killed either in an air strike
or
Crossfire I fear that's now been
realized Danielle Haman in Jerusalem
thank you Danielle now hours before that
Revelation the IDF announced the bodies
of three other hostages were found in
Gaza two were soldiers a third a foreign
National Hamas has released over 100 of
the more than 200 hostages it captured
during its attack on Israel 70 days ago
Israel has vowed to free all the
hostages and defeat Hamas but how the
offensive is being carried out is what
the US is pressuring its Ally to change
Crystal ganing reports and a warning
some of the images in her story are
disturbing the remains of three men a
28-year-old French Israeli Citizen and
Two Soldiers taken hostage during the
October 7th attacks have been located in
Northern Gaza the fate of those
kidnapped in the midst of Israel's
intense air and ground operation in Gaza
has been the focus of the group bring
them home now Israel is not backing down
on its pledged to eliminate
Hamas I say this in the face of great
pain but also in the face of
international pressures nothing will
stop
[Music]
us there is great pain a day after an
air strike in Rafa Palestinians sift
through the debris with their hands
desperate to locate their missing love
once we just removed a body it's been
here since yesterday afternoon we will
continue to reiterate both publicly and
privately our commitment to the notion
that every innocent life should be
sacred and should be protected Jake
Sullivan the US National Security
adviser was dispatched to the region to
press Israel to turn down the intensity
on the fighting in the densely populated
Enclave Israel's defense minister
thanked Sullivan for his visit but noted
their efforts against Hamas could take
several months Israel receives a
reported three .8 billion in American
Security assistance
annually the cost in terms of grief
immeasurable Al jazer late Friday had to
report on a death of one of their
own has died camera operator Samar aboda
was killed in a strike in Han Yunis Al
jazer said First Responders could not
get to him the Network's correspondent
Dadu was also so injured but was able to
make it to hospital Crystal Ganson
Global News London for the first time
since Israel's assault on Gaza began Aid
is entering the region through Israel's
Kim Shalom crossing the crossing sits at
the border between Israel Egypt and Gaza
Aid trucks were previously processed
there but had to return to Egypt's Rafa
Crossing to enter Gaza itself the faster
route should help Israel maintain its
commitment of allowing 200 Aid trucks
into Gaza each day there is horrible
news today out of Quebec that's
reverberating through hockey communities
across Canada an 11-year-old boy has
died after getting hit in the neck by a
puck during a practice this week Mike
Armstrong is in stach in Montreal's
Northshore with the details Mike well
far this appears to be just a very sad
fluke accident it happened at this Arena
Tuesday night police were called at
about 700 p.m. according to Witnesses
the 11-year-old boy was hit by a puck in
the neck he was taken to a local
hospital but then transferred to an
intensive care unit at a hospital in
Montreal it was the city that confirmed
this morning the boy had passed
away now there's a feeling of shock here
in the arena everyone we spoke to is
obviously saddened for the boy and his
family but also the person at the other
end of what happened what's the other
player the one who
accidentally hurt him you know you feel
sad for him oh my God the coroner's
office confirms it is investigating this
death and will offer recommendations if
there's something that could have been
done differently but neck protectors are
already mandatory in Quebec the boy was
wearing one that said they're made more
to protect from Cuts rather than impact
psychological support is being offered
to the community here and the Hockey
Association is encouraging people to
take advantage of it far Mike Armstrong
in Quebec thank you there are some
troubling numbers today that that are
out that could cause more financial
strain for Canadians in the years to
come the annual pace of housing starts
across the country plunged in November
down 22% from the month before that's
according to the Canada mortgage and
housing Corporation now if the current
rates of new construction continue IT
projects there will be a housing Supply
gap of about 3.5 million units by 2030
and as McKenzie gray reports the sharp
drop adds more pressure on the housing
crisis and more pressure to the federal
government
good morning everyone another day
another housing announcement from the
Liberals we've reached a deal with the
city of Vancouver that will see over
4,000 homes built over the next decade
that will cost $115 million from the
housing accelerator fund and in Exchange
Vancouver will change zoning laws and
cut red tape in one of Canada's most
unaffordable cities although we might be
living in a housing crisis it is
solvable and it's solvable if we put
measures on the table that will actually
result in more homes being built those
liberal measures centered around
increasing Supply but the exact opposite
is happening across the country in
November Vancouver saw a 39% drop in New
housing starts according to the Canada
mortgage and housing Corporation the
situation in Toronto was no better and
in Montreal a 30% cut the federal
housing agency blaming the 22% National
drop on high interest rates halting
primarily Construction of apartments and
condos we can't in you know expect that
the situation is going to change uh
anytime soon the development dip
combined with record population growth
is likely bad news for renters the
pressure on the rental stock will remain
also very very intense probably with
very low vacancy rates going forward and
and sustained upward pressure on on rent
the one cure to the building slowdown
interest rate cuts which many big Bank
economists believe will start in the the
middle of 2024 but that isn't even on
the radar of the Bank of Canada it's too
early to have that discussion we're
still discussing whether we've raise
interest rates enough on a yearly basis
the picture looks even worse this year
there'll be at least 8% fewer homes
built than in 2022 and far next year
that Trend looks like it'll
continue Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you the federal government is capping
how much money private broadcasters will
get under a $100 million deal with
Google ottawa's also rolled out a
timeline for meta that's the company
that owns Facebook and Instagram to
return to talks Heather urx West
explains online platforms like Google
and meta will have new rules to follow
starting next week and simply Banning
Canadian news content may not be enough
to escape fines the legislation will be
enforced on December 19 and the CTC will
have to examine which platforms fall
under the legislation and uh I'm sure
that crtc will pay close close attention
to Facebook and meta as of Monday large
online platforms and only Google and
meta are large enough to qualify must
start negotiating deals with Canadian
news outlets within 180 days Google has
already agreed to pay initial estimates
um of the impact of this bill were that
the broadcasters would stand the most to
benefit CBC Bell Media and chorus which
owns Global News employ roughly 2third
of all journalists in Canada but Ottawa
says their share of the $100 million
will be capped CBC will receive 7% of
the funds while private broadcasters
will split 30% there is a a bit of
disappointment um I think that this also
underscores that there is a real need to
look at other ways to help uh support
Broadcast News in Canada with
advertising revenue flowing to online
platforms the news industry has shed
thousands of jobs meta maintains its
Facebook and Instagram platforms provide
a service by Distributing Canadian news
content if the crtc finds that meta
falls under Canada's new regulations the
company could face millions of dollars
in fines Heather urx West Global News
Calgary Canada is sending four Griffin
helicopters to lvia next summer it's
part of a NATO mission to deter Russian
aggression defense minister Bill Blair
made the announcement on a trip to lvia
with Cada chief of the defense
staff will'll also be periodically
deploying shinook helicopters starting
in the fall and these aircraft will
boost our military capabilities on
NATO's Eastern
flank Blair also met with lvan leaders
and is visiting Canadian troops Canada's
already sent 15 leopard tanks to lvia
and is doubling the number of soldiers
stationed there to around 2200 by
2026 an Ontario mother's death is
Raising fresh questions about the
standard of care indigenous patients
receive in this country November Kelly
died earlier this year of a severe
infection her family says could have
been prevented and now they're looking
for answers and action for the alleged
mistreatment in part two of her
investigation Melissa Rin takes us to
onam in Western Ontario where many
indigenous Canadians say November's case
is far from
unique Carrie and Ron Kelly are grieving
parents looking for answers and they
just tell her I love her I tell her I
love her and I miss
her and I always ask
why
why why did you have to leave me last
year a car crash left November Kelly in
a thunderbay hospital with internal
injuries for the next four months she
complained to doctors in Fort Francis an
hour from her home on a nigging first
nation of worsening stomach pain it was
hard for me to get her to go because of
the way she was treated when she would
go she was visibly upset and asked her
what what's wrong I just got asked if I
was a needle user if I did
drugs and I was like oh my God like why
would they ask you that feeling unheard
and insulted November was often sent
home with pain and nausea medications at
one point she was given a fiber
supplement they just kept uh Band-Aid
Solutions and they kept telling um
telling us she's okay ultimately an
infection linked to a perforated bowel
suffered in the crash killed her the
health authority in Fort Francis tells
global news that they've launched a
review Kelly's family has filed a
complaint with the Ontario College of
Physicians and surgeons but igaming
first nation's Chief says that he
doesn't need a formal report to confirm
what many indigenous Canadians say
they've experienced for decades you're
still treated like you're just an Indian
in Canada especially by the doctors and
nurses and until that changes we're
still going to see misdiagnosis the
indigenous Physicians Association agrees
there is a lot of mistrust within the
Health Care system and and rightfully so
from First Nations main Inuit towards
the Health Care System Dr Mandy bu says
anti-indigenous bias continues in
healthc Care Systems across the country
we know these aren't unique and we've
heard of like Brian Sinclair and Joyce
Squan but we don't hear of all the
hundreds and thousands of cases that
happen and sometimes they don't lead to
death so they don't make it to Media um
but they lead to harm if she was just
treated like a normal human being she'd
be alive today and that's what we're
fighting for just the basics of humanity
that most Canadians take for granted the
Kelly say their daughter deserves
Justice something very wrong seem to
have happened here Medical Care is a
fundamental right shared by every single
person and it needs to be better so
where does this case rank um I'd say
about on as low an end as I could think
of back in igaming no MERS young son is
growing up without her and his sister
still struggles to understand their
mother's death she told me it was hard I
miss my mommy I've tried to bring her up
to the grave site a few times but she's
not ready a family and community in
mourning wondering if Canada's Health
Care system is ready to change Melissa
Ren Global News
Winnipeg Matthew Perry's cause of death
revealed that's coming up plus Prince
Harry scores legal Victory
next an autopsy has revealed
canadian-american actor Matthew Perry
accidentally died from the acute effects
of anesthetic ketamine the Los Angeles
medical examiner says he also drown in
his hot tub but that was a secondary
Factor coronary artery disease also
contributed to the death Perry was found
dead in his La home in October his
career spanned four decades he was best
known for his role as Chandler Bing on
the TV show Friends offset though he
battled substance abuse Perry was 54
years old Prince Harry has won his phone
hacking lawsuit against the publisher of
the Daily Mirror a judge found phone
hacking was quote widespread and
habitual at mirror group newspapers over
many years Harry was awarded nearly
$250,000 Canadian in compensation
Harry's lawyer read a statement from the
prince following the ruling today's
ruling is vindicating and affirming I've
been told that slaying dragons will get
you burned but in light of today's
Victory and the importance of what is
doing what is needed for a free and
honest press it is a worthwhile price to
pay harri had accused the mayor group of
using unlawful means to produce nearly
150 stories he's now calling for
authorities to lay charges against the
paper's editors and
[Music]
Executives ahead we hear from Sur
survivors of the deadly Manitoba bus
crash 6 months after the
tragedy 6 months ago a small Manitoba
Town received devastating news a bus
carrying 25 members of their Community
was involved in a fatal crash on the
Trans Canada Highway 17 people lost
their lives as a result of the collision
and it left eight others with
life-altering injuries now 6 months
later some of the survivors are sharing
their pain and their Journey with our
Marney
blunt I wanted to connect with so many
Embraces of
emotion once strangers now United in
grief and healing good 6 months after an
unthinkable tragedy changed all their
lives forever Bob Bernett and Alex senic
are survivors of the crash bonded as
friends for 30 years now also bonded as
survivors we were together which was a
good thing because we sat together in
the bus we got injured together in the
bus the pair remember little from that
fateful day in June I wish I could
remember I basically in a sense I don't
remember anything I remember getting on
the bus and that was the last thing I
remember waking up in a hospital the two
friends both in their 70s shared
hospital rooms in Winnipeg and Brandon
for about 2 months I remember being in H
well I think that what my daughter told
me it was Brandon uh Emergency Center or
whatever and I remember looking at the
walls and there was worms on the walls
you know I guess I was so
sedated and I remember them something
about sticking a tube in my
throat and then I remember bits in
pieces again for bobb's family the news
of his survival came with relief and
sadness I feel bad for this to this day
but I was so excited and happy I ran
across Ross the parking lot and I was I
was going he's alive he's alive and as I
did that I looked over and there was all
the families and they were crying
waiting for an
answer well that's what hurts you know
be why because I put him through stress
you know to see me like
that I can't I can't even imagine what
went through their head the two
discovering what happened after waking
up in hospital unfortunate be like I
know I got family I got a
girlfriend get around this way as for
Bob and Alex it's still a long road
ahead to recovery uh they're going to
have to carry me off that farm you know
as long as I'm capable and life is good
life goes on you got to live life you
got to GI to life live it if you want to
cry then you sit in the corner and cry
and they want to ensure the stories and
memories of the victims and survivors
are never forgotten somebody hasn't
forgotten let's
see everybody that was or or is on that
bus and many of the family members say
they hope this meeting will be the first
of many as they hope to reunite again
and also hope to one day meet the First
Responders to thank them in person Mar
blunt Global News
dolphin next socks as Savior is a couple
pairs up to keep toes toasty
we end tonight with a New Brunswick
couple helping people without a home and
they're starting with socks Shelley
Steves explains putting his socks on one
foot at a time it's something Dwayne
Hayes of New Brunswick once just took
for granted for someone who's homeless
you know they'll wear those socks until
they're worn out do that which is why he
and his wife got involved in 20K sock
Day last year New Brunswick collected
more than half of the 20,000 plus pairs
collected nationally thanks to the
efforts of these sock ambassadors the
premise is quite simple put a bin out
collect socks deliver them to uh to
homeless shelters in your area and then
just report back to us the number of
socks you collected the sock couple as
they've become known hey how you doing
how you doing are also getting ready to
take over running the national
initiative encouraging local businesses
across Canada to setup collection boxes
you know hypothermia is a big concern um
but I also think I hope that it makes
them feel valued you know that people
care about them hoping that donors
across the country will pull their socks
up too and donate as many pairs as
possible shadley Steves Global News
frederickton and that's global national
for this Friday tonight's your Canada is
Toronto's newly named sanova Square
formerly young Dundas Square the name
changed because of Henry dund das's role
in the trans Atlantic slave trade sanova
is again in concept of reclaiming the
past good
[Music]
night